[Musique]
inventer un organisme vivant sur mesure
l'idée semble relever de la
science-fiction pourtant c'est possible
et c'est grâce à la biologie synthétique
qu'on y arrive
voici une histoire pour le moins
inusitée une histoire où le personnage
principal à une vache ni un producteur
laitier mais plutôt un mutant pour bien
comprendre sa demande quelques
explications
d'abord pour produire du fromage ça
prend du lait beaucoup de lait pour 100
kg de lait entier on va faire un peu
près 10 kilos de fromage et on aura 90
kg de sous produit qui s'appelle le
petit lait de fromage ou le lactosérum
90% de sous-produits c'est énorme une
fois qu'on évapore le tout on obtient
des protéines et du lactose le sucre
naturel du lait sur le marché le lactose
ne vaut pratiquement rien les
transformateurs laitiers aimerait bien
pouvoir le valoriser c'est ici que
vincent martin entre en scène
ce microbiologiste croit avoir trouvé la
solution
pourquoi ne pas créer une nouvelle forme
de vie un mutant capable de transformer
le lactose en quelque chose de payants
aujourd'hui c'est possible grâce à la
biologie synthétique une discipline où
l'on manipule les jeunes à volonté
[Musique]
alors la même façon des ingénieurs pour
manipuler des structures des ponts etc
etc un
bien cette éthique on manipule les
génomes pour pour des objectifs assez
précis
est ici l'objectif est clair transformer
le lactose en un produit qui vaut 200
fois plus cher ce produit s'est lassé de
fûts maric un résidu du pétrole utilisé
en agroalimentaire et en pharmacologie
notamment comme ingrédient pour traiter
le psoriasis
on ne choisit l'acide fait marrer comme
étant un compromis entre la complexité
de réingénierie et la facilité d'arriver
à ce produit l'eau dans un temps
raisonnable parce qu'on pourrait aller
vers des choses beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus sophistiquées avec des valeurs
ajoutées très très élevé mais où la
complexité de la régénérer moléculaire
et est extrême
pour créer le design de leurs mutants
michel pilotes et vincent martens
s'inspire de la nature
quelques levure des champignons
unicellulaires peuvent transformer le
lactose en acide fut magique mais leur
taux de rendement est faible
parmi elles il y à celle où nom
imprononçable
on l'appellera quand même des lettres de
ses initiales
la levure de départ c'est notre notre
châssis seuls sur lesquels on construit
notre modèle c'est vraiment convertir
une petite voiture pas très performante
une voiture beaucoup plus performant qui
va être capable de performer
continuellement dans un milieu
industriel
[Musique]
oh
en premier lieu vincent martens a
séquencé le génome de cas m afin de
comprendre son fonctionnement
il veut savoir par quelle voie
métabolique via quels gènes elle
transforme le lactose
canton séquences de jeu non on obtient
la foulée voit les différentes voix de
maître à bord et que la levure et nous
en tant qu'ingénieur on doit décider
quelle voie sont les plus efficaces et
qu'elles voient devrait modifier ou
être incorporées dans le design
à l'écran le génome de la levure est
représenté par une longue série de
lettres c'est son code génétique les
instructions de sa fabrication
vincent martin joue avec lui à volonté
il conserve les partis qui l'intéressent
élimine celle dont il n'a pas besoin et
on peut retirer alors on peut enlever
certains gènes qui pour nous sont pas
importantes et qui pourrait causer des
problèmes où on peut incorporer certains
jeunes qui seraient pas nécessairement
leur génome de façon naturelle mais qui
serait important pour nous pour les
jeunes et non seulement c'est rentrer et
sortir des gènes du génome mes soucis
modifie l'expression du gène
pour décupler les pouvoirs de sa levure
vincent martin dispose de ressources
illimitées il peut utiliser n'importe
quel organisme vivant sur terre la
tomate la fourmi même l'éléphant
alors on peut retrouver le même gène
dans plusieurs organismes mais certains
gènes devons être plus performant que
d'autres gènes alors ça va c'est
vraiment un aspect important de la
biologie synthétique c'est de tester
différents gènes tester différentes
composantes dans son design pour
déterminer laquelle est la plus
performante
mais comment savoir si l'ajout d'un gène
d'augmenter ou non la production d'acide
fut maric leur logiciel sait prédire en
temps réel l'effet de chaque changement
il dit même la construction du mutant
et les modèles en question peut demander
pour l'éliminer mouture j'ai eu le
bonnet la question peut demander qu'on
incorpore plusieurs aux jeunes le modèle
touch me demander de tout simplement
changé l'expression certains gènes on
repose la même question est-ce que je
nouveaux modèles design est plus
performant que le que le design
préalable l'artiste passe à travers des
dizaines de milliers de différents
modèles à traiter rapidement
vincent martens crée ainsi des tonnes
d'organismes jamais vu sur terre mais à
cette étape ci ces créatures sont
numériques il faut leur donner vie ce
repos le seul exemplaire au canada
construit jeunes parviennent jusqu'à
2000 différents modèles de levure par
jour
une fois multiplié dans cet incubateur
qu'il faudra évaluer leurs performances
en présence du lactose
et si par inadvertance peu mutants
sortait du laboratoire pourrait-il se
reproduire et colonisé son environnement
leur milieu naturel une souche a besoin
de toutes sortes de gênes et autant de
fonctions pour survivre les conditions
du milieu naturel en général ces jeunes
et ces fonctions là pour nous sont soit
éliminé ou réduit encore points de
fonction a lancé son chien en question
sont beaucoup moins compétitives dans un
milieu naturel mais beaucoup plus
compétitive dans un milieu industriel
le projet d'un groupe sûrs et de
l'université concordia démarre à peine
la première génération de culture
optimisé verra le jour d'ici trois ans
utiliser le lactose et non pas le
pétrole pour produire de l'acide fut
maric tout cela grâce à une levure fait
sur mesure voilà une histoire qui vaut
son pesant d'or
[Musique]